seit einem Jahr
wehrt sich die Ukraine auf erstaunliche
Weise für seine Unabhängigkeit seine
Freiheit und für das Recht sich eine
eigene Zukunft aufzubauen ich stehe hier
vor Ihnen und spreche für Frankreich und
wir sind entschlossen die Ukraine zu
unterstützen dass sie sich nicht nur
wehren kann sein rechter Verteidigung
ausüben kann ein rechters in unserer
Gemeinsamkeiten anerkannt wird sondern
und auch dass es seine territoriale
Unversehrtheit verteidigen kann auch
dies sind Prinzipien die uns vereinen
dass die Ukraine also sich gegen die
russische Aggression wären kann die
internationale Sicherheit und Stabilität
geht und somit auch die Sicherheit unser
aller bedroht
dies würde niemand keinem unserer
Staaten so gute kommen denn es hilft
niemandem wenn Aggressoren unterstützt
werden
dieser Krieg von Russland geht uns alle
etwas an es bedroht die Existenz eines
Staates
durch ein imperialistisches Projekt es
leugnet die internationalen Grenzen das
geht uns alle etwas an ja
macron hat hier im September gesagt dass
es keine Neutralität gibt denn bei
Qualität bedeutet zum Komplizen des
Angreifers zu werden
Russland die Regeln diktieren zu lassen
hätte verheerende Folgen für die
internationale Rechtsordnung der wir uns
seit 75 Jahren verschreiben die
russische Aggression könnte der erste
Schritt im Hinblick auf eine der
Eskalation sein unter der wir alle
leiden würden
niemand von uns hätte dann Grund dafür
sich sicher zu fühlen im Hinblick auf
eine Land das Atomwaffen besitzt und dem
UN-Sicherheitsrat angehört und tut was
es möchte Herr Präsident seit einem Jahr
engagiert sich diese Versammlung im
Hinblick auf die inakzeptable Situation
seitdem 24 Februar hat sie vier sich
viermal geäußert im für die
Unabhängigkeit und Souveränität der
Ukraine heute haben wir die Möglichkeit
diese Regeln und Prinzipien wieder
hochzuhalten denn ohne diese wäre unsere
Kunden unsere Katha leere Worte brauchen
wir einen nachhaltigen Frieden sowie wie
wir die alle dies möchten
entsprechende Tradition
Frankreichs unterstützt mein Land diese
Resolution und ruft alle Staaten dazu
auf dasselbe zu tun
verantwortlicherweise vielen Dank
Positionen zur ukrainischen Krise ist
konsistent und klar die Souveränität und
territuelle Unverletzlichkeit aller
Länder müssen respektiert werden
Zweck und Grundsätze der un-kater müssen
betrachtet werden
die legitimen Sicherheitsinteressen bei
aller Länder müssen ernst genommen
werden alle Bemühungen die zu einer
friedlichen Lösung der Krise führen
müssen unterstützt werden in der
gegenwärtigen Situation möchte ich
folgende vier Punkte aus chinesischer
Sicht vorstellen erstens höchste
Priorität hat die Förderung eines
Waffenstillstands Einstellung der
Feindseligkeiten unverzüglich Konflikt
Konflikte und Kriege haben keinen
Gewinner je länger die Brutalität
andauert desto größer Mensch
einmal mehr rufen wir die
Konfliktparteien auf
Wege aus der Sackgasse zu suchen und zu
verhindern dass die Krise schlimmer wird
oder gar außer Kontrolle gerät
alle Konfliktparteien müssen sich streng
an die Konventionen für nukleare
Sicherheit halten und Atomunfälle
verhindern Atomwaffen dürfen nicht
eingesetzt werden ein Atomkrieg darf
nicht gefochten werden alle Parteien
müssen die Bedrohung des Einsatzes von
Atomwaffen zurückweisen die
weiterverwaltung von Atomwaffen
verhindern und eine
nuklear-krise verhindern zweitens Dialog
und Verhandlung sind der einzige
gangbare Weg zur Lösung der ukrainischen
Krise zu Beginn der Krise haben Russland
und die Ukraine mehrere Gesprächsrunden
gehabt und wichtige Fortschritte erzielt
leider sind die Friedensgespräche nicht
mehr weitergegangen die Gründe geben
anders zu Sorge und erfordern nachdenken
die Lehren der Geschichte sagen uns doch
das Krisen wie tief sie auch sein mögen
letzten Endes friedlich gelöst werden
können egal wie schwierig es ist die Tür
zu einer politischen Lösung darf nicht
zugeschlagen werden drittens
die
internationale Völkergemeinschaft sollte
sich bemühen Friedensgespräche zu
ermöglichen
brutale Fakten beweisen hinlänglich das
Waffenlieferungen keinen Frieden
erbringen werden sie schütten Öl ins
Feuer
verschärfen nur noch die Spannungen die
Verlängerung und Ausweitung des
Konflikts wird nur dazu führen dass sie
einfachen Menschen einen höheren Preis
zahlen müssen wir wiederholen unseren
Apfel das Diplomatie und Verhandlungen
nicht einfach fallen gelassen werden
dürfen wir brauchen Anstrengungen in
Richtung Waffenstillstand eine
gemeinsame Sicherheit und ein
dauerhafter Frieden kann nur erreicht
werden wenn wir festhalten das
Sicherheit kein Vorrecht einiger Länder
nur ist die Sicherheit eines Landes darf
nicht erreicht werden auf Kosten der
Sicherheit anderer Länder
die große Blöcke weiter noch zu
verstärken wird nur dazu führen dass die
regionale Sicherheit untergraben wird
und den Frieden in weitere Ferne wirken
wir sind entsetzt
unverfrorene Verletzung der
internationalen Ordnung ich Russland die
uncut ist binnen für alle
Mitgliedstaaten inklusive Russland
Russland muss sich sofort vollständig
und bedingungslos
zurückziehen mit seinen Streitkräften
aus dem gesamten Gebiet der Ukraine
innerhalb ihrer international
anerkannten Grenzen
die Tschechische Republik steht an der
Seite der Ukraine und
bekennt sich zu Unterstützung des
Wunsches der Ukraine nach einem
gerechten Frieden gemäß der windkater
die russische Aggression verursacht
unrechtliches Leid in der Ukraine und
darüber hinaus hat eine Schockwelle
durch die Lebensmittel und
Rohstoffmärkte der Welt gesandt und
droht und 50 Millionen Menschen an den
Rand des Hungers zu treiben in Afrika
und andersrum die unterstützen die
Schwarzmeer Getreide Initiative und die
unbemühungen
diese Initiative weiter auszuweiten wir
begrüßen das un-handeln
gegen die weiteren Konsequenzen des von
Russland verursachten Krieges und der
Bedrohung der Lebensmittelsicherheit
weltweit wir müssten uns alle bewusst
darüber sein dass jedes Land das nächste
Opfer Russland sein kann die Zukunft der
internationalen Ordnung wird jetzt
entschieden die Ukraine verteidigt nicht
nur sich selbst und das eigene Volk
sondern verteidigt auch die
grundsätzlichen Prinzipien der endcarda
Bemühungen Praktiken zu legitimieren wie
den Einsatz von Gewalt um geopolitische
Ziele zu erzielen oder Lebensmittel
Erpressung und nukleäres säbelratteln zu
legitimieren müssen entschlossen
zurückgewiesen werden die Erkenntnisse
der un- untersuchungsmission sind
schockierend
Tieren sexuelle Gewalt und Folter als
russische Kriegstaktik
wir machen uns große Sorgen über die
Angriffe der russischen Streitkräfte
rund um die Atomkraftwerke der Ukraine
und auch angesichts der illegalen
Besetzung des atomgeschirr die
für die
Kriegsverbrechen Verantwortlichen müssen
zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden
inklusive der Verantwortung für diesen
Angriffskrieg die für die Angriffskrieg
verantwortliche Führung darf nicht
ungestraft davonkommen lassen das hieß
sie nämlich den Kampf gegen
Straflosigkeit aufzugeben und die
Aggression noch anzuhalten
der Krieg hat über 8 Millionen Ukraine
aus der Landesbetrieben im Geist der
Solidarität hat Tschechien die Türen
geöffnet was eine halbe Million Menschen
haben bei uns tomorien Schutz gefunden
die meisten von ihnen Frauen und Kinder
wir bleiben das Land mit der größten
Anzahl ukrainischer Flüchtlinge pro Kopf
obwohl das natürlich Problem und
Herausforderung mit sich bringen für den
Staat und unsere Bürger insbesondere in
Zeiten der Wirtschaft und Energiekrise
unser Land und unser Volk hat
beispiellose Solidarität an den Tag
gelegt
im vergangenen Jahr haben die Ukraine
und ihr Volk enormen Mut bewiesen und
Widerstandskraft gezeigt indem sie nicht
nur ihr Land verteidigt haben sondern
die gesamte regelbasierte internationale
Ordnung wir spenden Beifall für die
heroischen verteidigungsanstrengung die
es geschafft haben die Invasion
aufzuhalten und den Mythos der
russischen militärischen Unbesiegbarkeit
zu zerstören die Vereinten Nationen
haben
signifikante Solidarität bewiesen die
überwiegende Mehrheit der Mitglieder hat
die russische Aggression verurteilt als
Unfall ohne Verletzung der un-karte und
in Resolution nach Resolution haben wir
zum unbedingungslosen Rückzug der
russischen Truppen aufgerufen
diese Versammlung hat Russland auch den
Sitz des Menschen im Menschenrechtsrat
entzogen an lektionsreferent für illegal
erklärt unternommen für internetanismen
für russische Reparationen an die
Ukraine die Bemühungen des
endgeneralsekretärs haben entscheidend
dazu beigetragen dass ukrainische
Getreide an die zu liefern die es
brauchen und es wurde ein unabhängigen
Untersuchungskommission eingerichtet die
jetzt die Kriegsverbrechen in der
Ukraine untersucht von seinem Russland
während Russland sich in
Schuldzuweisungen versucht geht es
eigentlich darum Einfluss werden zu
schaffen Instabilität zu sehen und
andere Völker zu dominieren das erinnert
an koloniale Zeiten die diese
Organisation so entschlossen war für
immer hinter sich zu lassen Russland
setzt die zulassen das Russland
strafloss agiert da der
UN-Sicherheitsrat wirksam gelähmt bleibt
durch Mist den Missbrauch des Motorräder
rechts durch Russland
wird die Rolle und die Verantwortung der
Generalversammlung immer wichtiger wir
Mitgliedstaaten müssen uns unserer
Verantwortung stellen indem wir
Präsident selenskys friedensformen
unterstützen die auf den Grundsätzen der
un-kater beruht und auf einer
regelbasierten internationalen Orten
sondern allererst müssen wir zum
vollständigen Rückzug der Invasion
besetzen Gebieten auffordern und Sie
sollten uns nicht davor scheuen die
entschlossene militärische Hand Aktionen
der Ukraine zu unterstützen wir müssen
die Täter zur Rechenschaft ziehen wir
begrüßen die Bemühungen durch den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
regionale Körperschaften und
Einzelstaaten die ihnen zu verfolgen die
für Kriegsverbrechen Verbrechen gegen
die Humanität und Genozid verantwortlich
sind wir sollten alles tun um
sicherzustellen das russische
Vermögenswerte genutzt werden um
Entschädigung zu lassen und seelische
Schäden die Aggression angerichtet
wurden wir begrüßen die ersten Stütze
Schritte dahin die ist ermöglichen das
Recht auf Reparation einzufordern der
Vorsitzer liebe Kollegen mit der
heutigen Resolution die Litauen
unterstützt möchten wir alle Bemühungen
fördern für einen umfassenden gerechten
und dauerhaften Frieden gemäß der Karte
der Vereinten Nationen
und von der Vollversammlung in den
UN-Sicherheitsrat der wird sich morgen
am Jahrestag des russischen Angriffs mit
der Ukraine befassen und hier kann
Russland ja mit seinem Vetorecht jeden
Beschluss blockieren trotzdem der
Sicherheitsrat gilt als das wichtigste
als das mächtigste Instrument der
Vereinten Nationen Europas Chefdiplomat
Josip Borell hat dort heute für eine
Zusammenarbeit zwischen der EU und der
UNO geworden
das war jetzt das dritte Mal dass ich
vor dem Sicherheitsrat gesprochen habe
und leider hat sich an meiner Botschaft
nichts geändert
darauf hingewiesen dass es ein Defizit
beim Multi dass wir globale Notlage
haben dass wir kollektive Lösungen
brauchen dass wir gemeinsam zu schwachs
sind und die Antwort stärken müssen in
dieser Woche jährlich ja in der einmal
Russland in die Ukraine und insofern ist
es wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass wir
multilaterale Lösungen brauchen denn in
einer Welt wo die illegale anwälderung
von Gewalt durch ein ständiges mit der
Sicherheit
als normal ansehen wird dann gibt es
keine Hoffnung mehr für Gerechtigkeit
und Freiheit das sind einfach wichtige
Dinge die wir besprechen müssen
Gespräche mit Sicherheitsrat heute
vormittag wurde auch klar welche
positive Rolle die EU gespielt hat und
ich bedanke mich dafür dass 14 der 15
Mitglieder des Sicherheitsrat ist das
auch gewürdigt haben um unsere
Zusammenarbeit mit der Afrikanischen
Union was Frieden und Sicherheit
anbelangt mit dem Partner in Asien was
die Konnektivität anbelangt es geht auch
um das Thema Klimawandel wir müssen die
grüne Wände beschleunigen aber es muss
eine Fähre eine gerechte Wände sein
ansonsten kommt es nicht dazu denn die
Verantwortung für dieses Problem
ist eben groß und diejenigen die dieses
Problem am wenigsten verschuldet haben
werden am stärksten davon betroffen und
deshalb habe ich noch mal darauf hin
lesen wie wichtig das für uns ist wir
sind ja der größte Geldgeber was
staatliche Gelder für die
klimaabendfinanzierung anbelangt das
reicht immer noch nicht aber wir sind
der größte Geldgeber als EU mit 23
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr und dann haben
wir es natürlich auch mit Notlagen zu
tun wie der Pandemie oder auch
in der Ukraine
ist für das Engagement dass sie von uns
auch in anderen Bereichen erwarten
Entwicklungshilfe Klima ja wir sind ja
ein großer Geldgeber der größte
Geldgeber auch im Bereich der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit aber wir
müssen noch mehr tun für mich ist es
klar
Entwicklungsfragen auf
gleichberechtigter Grundlage mit unseren
Partnern arbeiten sollten wir sollten
Hinwirken auf eine Reform der weltweiten
finanziellen Architektur um sie fairer
und effektiver zu gestalten und wir
müssen unseren Beitrag zu dieser
Diskussion helfen damit die globale
finanzielle architekturf und effektiver
wird und unsere Mitgliedstaaten müssen
auch mehr Führungsqualitäten zeigen im
Rahmen des IDF und bei der Weltmarkt und
natürlich geht es nicht nur darum dass
wir unsere
sondern ist es auch in unserem ureigenen
Interesse und angesichts der
geopolitischen Position in der EU etwas
was notwendig ist und das ergibt sich
letztlich auch aus dem Umfeld das durch
die russische Aggression gegen die
Ukraine entstanden ist
wir müssen sehen werden als diejenigen
die bereits sind auch die gegenwärtige
institutionelle Struktur in Frage zu
stellen offen mit unseren Partnern
weltweit auf gleichberechtigte Ebene
darüber zu sprechen